texe world is a text-based game
generator that you can use to train and
evaluate reinforcement learning agents
it is an open-source project put out by
Microsoft Research Montreal and can be
found at a kms forward slash text world
click on get the code to access our
github repo installing Tex world is
quick and easy
just type pip install Tex world
text-based games are great tools for AI
research because to succeed at a
text-based game an AI needs to
understand language common-sense
reasoning how to deal with a
combinatorial action space and how to
overcome common reinforcement learning
problems like partial observability and
rewards sparsity these skills are
ultimately key skills needed for
artificial general intelligence with
text world you can quickly and easily
generate a large distribution of
training games while controlling for
various aspects of the game such as the
quest complexity the vocabulary the
action and state space the reward
density and the amount of information
provided to agents you can also use text
world to handcraft games in order to
test specific skills with text world you
can train and test on different but
related games try out a text world
generated game for yourself first use
the TW make command to create a game
that has 5 rooms 10 objects and 5 tasks
then play the game you just created
using the TW play command in this game
there is a type s passkey on the counter
so one action you can do is take it
[Music]
there is also a help command that can be
made use of if you choose you can play
the game with hints which gives
suggested commands that can be used on
the text world github repo you can
access detailed Python notebooks that
walk you step-by-step through how to
build a random agent a new agent and how
to handcraft a specific text world game
you'll need PI torch to run the notebook
and with that you should be set with
getting started using Tex world for more
information please go to aka.ms/offweb
[Music]
forward slash Tex world - challenge for
more details